you've got this you've got a right wing
right now that is
that doesn't have very much holding it
together and the conservatives are
becoming more conservative and the
libertarians are becoming more
libertarian we don't have the old soviet
union to hold us together the left is
getting so much more aggressive they
barely see any distinction between
anyone on the right anyway they want to
just kill us all and salt the earth on
which we once stood
is there someone who can bring us
together in 2024 say whether that's your
governor whether that's trump whether
that's someone else in the country is
there someone who can do it or do we
need to wait for a new candidate
the very people who for the last however
many years have told us how much we
should hate evil corporations right
corporations have too much power over us
and they buy too much political
influence and they must be evil and
they're somehow capitalistic that's
doubly evil who do they love right now
they love disney they love the most evil
corporation in the world that is trying
i mean
desantis is literally fighting disney
tooth and nail right now to keep their
policies out of floridian's classrooms
he's the guy that was
elected to be executive chief executive
of the state now you may not like his
policies but that's what his job is but
the pa this and that's what i mean about
people flipping all of their beliefs
based on politics and you can't
disconnect that from people that don't
have a belief in something else if you
just believe that on any given day
whatever happens whatever happens
politically or culturally that's reality
you are going to be freaking crazy
especially in an age of algorithms and
big tech and bots and everything else if
you're if your world view
is this got a lot of retweets that guy
said the thing and he's wearing the lab
coat and the rest of it
and the fact that you know and the book
does go quite heavy into this too the
mainstream media has lied to us about
absolutely everything so now you take a
bunch of people who maybe don't have a
very strong original
say base view of the world they haven't
figured out if they believe or they
don't believe they're not sure if they
believe in individual rights or what
they really believe you take them
they're already sort of shaking now you
take
a pandemic you throw it on top of that
now they're really kind of crazy and
scared and everything else and then you
take a media that has literally lied
about everything from hunter biden to
brett kavanaugh as a racist to the
covington kids to kyle written houses of
white supremacists to very fine people
on both sides to the litany to jesse
smilet we could do this all day yeah
well of course you're going to end up
with a population that is half insane
population that half of it is insane
right right
you you bring up your governor down
there in florida
you brought him up a few times now dave
uh so
i have to ask we're having this
wonderful religious
cultural philosophical conversation by
the way you're a great host i just want
to say really by the way
get out of here you're going to make me
blush come on if i weren't so tan i'd
blush
but i i want to i want to i want to put
all that good stuff aside for a second
and talk about
rough hard
nuts and bolts politics because this is
a you know big theme of the book and
what we're talking about here what are
you going to do about it you've got this
you got a right wing right now that is
doesn't have very much holding it
together and the conservatives are
becoming more conservative and the
libertarians are becoming more
libertarian we don't have the old soviet
union to hold us together the left is
getting so much more aggressive they
barely see any distinction between
anyone on the right anyway they want to
just kill us all and salt the earth on
which we once stood
is there someone who can bring us
together in 2024 say whether that's your
governor whether that's trump whether
that's someone else in the country is
there someone who can do it or do we
need to wait for a new candidate well
first as i try to make the argument in
the book you know politics is not going
to save us here so it is the stuff
that's going to save us is what we
started talking about which is the build
new things figure out your community and
your life and all that however politics
is not nothing there is a reason that we
do this for a living and even if we want
even if in the world that you and i
michael want to live in politics should
be small enough to fit you know in a
little box that we can tuck away in our
pocket that's not what we have right now
so we have to fight for that let's say
um and and at the end of the day the
size of that thing may be a little bit
different for for the two of us um i
would say this about desantis look it is
not going to get better than him it
really isn't in an american context of
politics with a deeply corrupt media i
would say at this point an evil
corporate press
you are not going to get a better guy
than this he's 42 43 years old military
background he is fearless in fighting
the media i i've now i've had dinner
with him a few times and i've i've spoke
to him a couple of times and i've
listened i've gone to events where he's
spoken at and i can tell you this guy
he does not want to be king he does not
want to be your ruler he he's a guy that
sort of it doesn't even sound at some
level like he wants to be president like
he really sounds like a guy that should
be
and i guess this is a little bit of the
trump thing that he should be running a
business he's like i say things i make
decisions we see what happens and then
you know i do it again he he doesn't get
affected by polls um he's strong he's
picking the right fights you know he's
you know and i say all this without i
don't worship politicians i i obviously
i happen to i like and admire the guy
obviously um but i like and admire him
because of the reasons that because of
the
fact that he wants to mostly stay out of
our lives the point of the don't say gay
bill
h-1557 which again has the word gay
isn't in it and they could have just as
easily called it don't say straight bill
because you're not allowed to talk about
straight sex with a second grader
obviously you morons um the point of the
bill was to keep the government out of
these things that state employees
shouldn't be discussing these things
with kids it's not more government it's
less government actually it's the
government reining in what state
employees can do
so that to me is the type of thing that
we want now we have a great
problem i would say a good problem here
in florida which is that he's up for
re-election obviously in november he's
going to win by a landslide i think he's
well he's going to win and i hope and i
believe it will be by a landslide and
then what i hope happens from that is
that landslide then really causes the
states to to start going like dominoes
won by you know we got the yunkan win it
was pretty damn close desantis will win
by more hopefully texas stays
red tennessee's obviously going to stay
red you're going to be fine but then
some of the places that could go either
way a colorado indiana okay
that they're going to fully go red
and then it doesn't mean that everyone
in those red states is going to have
every perfect republican party platform
i always remind it i write about him in
the book in a different context but
everyone thinks and knows that rudy
giuliani obviously is a conservative
rudy giuliani happens to be pro-choice
but no one's doubting that he's a
conservative and that you would want
rudy giuliani on your side regardless of
the you know the bad hair dye dripping
down his head and and some of the
yelling and everything else i mean he's
a good guy you would want him on your
side he's a fighter so i want to say
this to crush here
and then i suppose after crushing here
crushing here that then he is the best
candidate for 24
the trump thing is what confuses this
would the best situation be that trump
is the bodyguard run the rallies fight
for the platform and the party in the
country and let desantis go through
that's the best situation can trump do
that does he want to do that does he
want to put his ego aside to do that i'm
not sure and the other problem with the
trump thing and i and i look forward to
interviewing him again
and i hope if you interview him that you
could ask him this directly which is
that the fear with the trump thing i
think there's two real things which is
one would the machine allow him to win
right right whatever it would even be
possible right would it even be possible
that's number one and number two even if
you accept that the machine would
whatever i mean by that
the base of the democrats is so
depressed right now their candidate has
dementia and the backup woman is is i
think
uh has the equivalent let's say iq of
maybe a sixth grader
she was polling at zero in her own party
everything is a mess right now inflation
gas prices they made up the war the
other thing it's all terrible
but suddenly if trump runs you can
probably get five million extra people
to show up out of the woodwork just
because they hate trump so trump really
has to acknowledge those things and
again that's not a knock on trump and i
really would ask him that to his face
what he thinks about that
but all of that being put aside i think
there's such a rich opportunity for a
truly
interesting wide tent republican party
right now but it's going to be work for
us man it really is if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell